hardly anyone visits this place on the
tunisian coast under the sand here are
the remains of women children and young
men they drowned in the Mediterranean
chasing an uncertain dream a dream of
life in Europe their stories lie buried
with them in these makeshift graves no
names no identities no headlines across
from the sea over there in Europe the
focus has shifted from how to help
migrants to how to keep migrants here he
wants to give them dignity
shamsid-deen is a fisherman here near
the tourist hotspot of zarzis he has
buried the remains of 300 people to stop
the crossings Europe has proposed the
creation of so-called disembarkation
platforms in North Africa their migrants
would be able to apply for asylum
shamsid-deen isn't impressed doesn't
care about these people whether they're
alive or dead building reception centres
isn't a solution instead Europe should
give people the wealth that was stolen
from them a beach near the cemetery this
is where fishermen discovered the
washed-up bodies shamsid-deen wants to
find them before the local children do I
am on my way to a nearby migrant center
where some of those rescued find
temporary refuge there I meet the - from
the Democratic Republic of Congo for
months she was a sex slave in Libya she
tells me when they discovered that I was
pregnant they let me go I don't want to
stay here in Tunisia I want to go to
Europe Tunisia has no functioning asylum
system and it has to not only deal with
migrants passing through but also with
increasing numbers of its own youths who
dream of a brighter future these young
men died trying to reach Italy more than
7000 Tunisians tried to cross the
Mediterranean last year while was one of
them he invites me to his home to share
his story
there's no hope here I'm neither dead
nor alive it's all the same we don't
have any jobs in the future nothing this
country kills our dreams that's why I
want to escape well survived several
boat accidents in the Mediterranean but
he's undeterred he wants to try again
Kofi Tunis if I stay here in Tunisia I
have zero hope in Europe I at least have
a chance but Europe doesn't want to take
in migrants like well so who exactly is
responsible for those rescued at sea we
have to stop treaty migrants like
hostages and using them as political
leverage we have to stop treating them
as a tool with which to get money from
Europe and we have to be humane with
them and guarantee them the right of
freedom of movement Tunisia s government
has repeatedly said it does not want to
be the gatekeeper for migrants trying to
reach Europe caught in limbo thousands
si trying their luck on the
Mediterranean as the only option despite
the dangers